[Music]
this morning on the dish a world
traveler whose passion for food is
contagious Adam Richman was born and
raised in Brooklyn and loved a sample of
the taste that his diverse neighborhood
had to offer and he did the same when he
headed off to Emory University in
Atlanta actually keeping a food journal
of his favorite spots across the
southeast
he worked in a variety of restaurant
jobs later attended the Yale School of
Drama and then managed to combine all of
those interests food travel performing
into a thriving TV career he's been the
host of a half-dozen shows and is now
the host of secret eats with Adam
Richman
on The Cooking Channel Adam Richman good
morning welcome to the dish thank you so
much for having us for coming in this is
a spectacular table and tell us about
this spread okay so the quick rundown of
course we'll start with dessert so I
have my win the bake sale chocolate cake
vegetables rib eye over arugula avocado
with some sea salt and a mom a sweet
corn succotash and smoked paprika onion
rings and to drink Alamos Malbec sangria
don't mind if I do
best way to start the day sure is mm-hmm
so we mentioned you keep you kept a
cooking journal a food journal whenever
in college mm-hmm it was really kind of
random I had a bad breakup I bought one
of all scheme books to write sort of
that cheesy black turtleneck clothes
smoking College breakup poetry and I
would often go for drives in Atlanta and
I found this place and I began writing
about the meal and all those feelings
came out sort of organically you know
and I think that I realized that food
could be the point of departure to
explore my feelings Atlanta the
atmosphere in the world around me and so
that's how the food journal began and
then it sort of grew because I wanted to
find places to take dates that all the
other guys with dirty white baseball
caps and it built and then as I did
regional theater after Yale I began to
augment the journal and it really helped
with my maverick dishes so how does a
guy go from Yale to doing all the you
know I guess that quite a bit well to be
fair I've been working in the food
industry since I was 13 in some capacity
actually a little younger I had a um a
potato chip and lemonade stand
my late father helped me build on the
corner of Avenue u and home crest Avenue
in Brooklyn but I think that I've always
innately been a performer and I think
that having a bit of culinary acumen and
an idea of just on-camera comportment
and the ability to push the narrative
structure of a story even if that story
is of a 10 pound burrito that you know I
think that there is a link what as you
mentioned you mean because you were you
had virtually every job there was in
food before you went to dramas yes sir
you mean you were a sushi chef you were
a busboy you were you know you did
pretty much everything sir but so so
what what propelled you back to drama
school I think that I wanted to truly
get the craft to craft training and
having a master's degree would always
allow me the security of being able to
teach and I like teaching I'm on faculty
in a couple of acting schools yeah so I
did that but to be fair the acting that
I was able to do as a result of being a
Yale School of Drama graduate ended up
taking me to the Cleveland Playhouse
yeah me too the San Jose Playhouse took
me to the Alabama Shakespeare Festival
for a year so suddenly you're trying
burgoo and ciaochao and gooey butter
cake anomalous and emos pizza toasted
ravioli and you go into restaurants like
original Joe's in San Jose so then when
I finally auditioned for man vs. food in
late 2008 I'm not just a kid whose only
purview is Brooklyn I could actually
speak to the nation as a whole right
tell us about your latest show secret
eats so secret eats is about hidden
restaurants and off menu dishes all over
the world right these are the dishes
that you have to have a password to get
the dish where you have to there's a
place in Hong Kong we have to walk
through a hardware store through the
foundation of a building through the
back alley to find a restaurant that was
built in the 60s that has amazing like
three or four menu items but
breathtaking there's a place in Mexico
that's old Mayan gold reliquary in a
cave that's three stories into the
ground that's now a restaurant but
there's also places right here in New
York cienfuegos the Lower East Side el
sabroso brilliant Latin cuisine on a
loading dock in the fashion district
right so let's be honest I'm not some
trained highly trained chef from CIA and
I think that people caught into my
programming
because I'd like being as the rapper
Paul Wall says the People's Champ so I
feel that if I could convey these places
that make everyone feel like the man
then I think that that's the appeal and
plus my crews in the show and they never
get their love and they work their
Tisha's off so it's my honor to show
them speaking of a deal having you here
has been wonderful I want to ask you and
ask if you could sign this I would be
honored and if you could tell us if you
could share this with anyone past or
present who would you share this meal
with my dad my dad passed in 98 and so
he saw me on the struggle and I think
he'd be very proud of the way I've taken
care of my mom and my stepmom and I've
established a couple of I've either
given awards or grants in his name and
in his honor so and he was a great cook
so I think my dad would really would
like this meal and it would be nice just
to share one more meal with him I think
this one's for Dad
this one is for dad Adam Richman I want
to thank you so much for joining us
you've your chocolate cake is divine I
might need anthony's to with this revolt
and for more on Adam Richman and the
dish please head to our website
cBS This Morning Calm